ce n'est pas sous les meilleurs auspices
que la lieu là aujourd'hui la visite des
manuels macron c'est son quinzième et
dernier grand débat la corse comme
dernière étape ce n'était peut-être pas
le meilleur choix
voici comment le président de l'exécutif
corse gilles simeoni justifie son appel
au boycott
nous pensons que malheureusement les
règles du débat de demain ne permettront
pas d'aborder l'ensemble des problèmes
qui nous qui nous paraissait essentiel
nous aurions souhaité pouvoir participer
à ce débat en l'élargissant la pression
avec la perspective en inscrivant ce
moment de rencontre dans une vision plus
large en impliquant l'ensemble des
acteurs et en nous situant dans cette
perspective historique que le président
de la république dit lui-même vouloir
c'est pas possible pour l'instant et
donc forcément il ya un sentiment de
frustration
pas forcément très clair je pense qu'on
est enfant on est face à deux dans un
dialogue on dit d'eux sous deux formes
d'autisme la l'autisme nationaliste et
certaines formes d'autisme aussi chez
makro je pense qu'ils ont raté quelque
chose entre simeoni et macron je pense
que l'an dernier lorsque macron est
arrivé pour la clé pour commémorer la
mort de madame erignac il a évidemment
bien fait mais il fallait à mon avis
saisir l'opportunité d'un dialogue
particulier avec gilles thimonier parce
que si gilles simeoni est quelqu'un de
très populaire dans l'île il a une
certaine légitimité au delà de son camp
c'est un homme intelligent c'est un
homme raisonnable
on n'est pas forcément d'accord avec ses
perspectives mais c'est un homme avec
qui on peut discuter et je pense que oui
mais je pense que non il n'y a pas de
discussion possible avec jean michel
meunier on peut pas discuter de l'avenir
de la corse française pour quelqu'un
pour qui la corse n'est pas française
donc l'occasion du dialogue était
offerte nous dit paul françois paoli
vous êtes d'accord hervé nathan s'éteint
non plus qu'il n'a pas été saisi moi je
pense que c'était c'était peine perdue
c'est la chasse est d'accord c'est qu'on
est face à deux de sorte d'autisme
alors j'ai parlé d' autisme présidence
et alors pour le coup parce que il est
en train d'arriver enfin et le prénom à
public devrait se rendre compte que il
passe son temps à contourner le dialogue
avec les corps constitués et puis
ensuite il est bien obligé d'aller les
deux d'ailleurs trouvé ça risque de lui
revenir en boomerang cette fois ci il
avait décidé de pallier au congrès les
maires nommé oui mais il avait commencé
par dire je n'irai pas au congrès des
maires il avait commencé par dire les
corps reposent les corps intermédiaires
ça n'existe pas la cfdt a été mis de
côté dès le début du conflit des délits
et jaune et là ils sont en train
d'essayer de retrouver les mères c'est
pareil ils sont vraiment très utile
cette fois-ci présent un public a décidé
de contourner la représentation
démocratique décor ce n'est pas du
peuple corse et des corses puissent
qu'ils ont et c'est comme ça il nous
certaine manière la question de les
relations entre la corse et le continent
la berd a coiffé la france dont certains
je veux pas trancher là dessus et elle
sera bien et sera bien obligé présent un
public avant la fin de son mandat de
dire quelque chose de précis là-dessus
et de discuter effectivement avec
monsieur avec le président de l'exécutif
quelque chose qui à mon avis a été
désastreux encore c'est que je pense que
ma croix comme une erreur psychologique
ou politique
quand il est allé à marseille il a il
s'est adressé aux marseillais comoriens
il a fait en sorte de discours
communautariens ou communautariste
lorsque avant les élections il a été
démagogues à mes yeux un il a parlé aux
comoriens aux algériens il salua étaient
reprochés et quand il va encore s'il
prend une posture jacobine les corps se
disent n'y a qu'à nous qu'il rappelle
que la république est une et indivisible
donc c'est à mon avis macron n'a pas de
réflexion de fond sur la question sur
les cycliques et sur les questions des
communautés en france et notamment de la
communauté
je vous donne la parole à tous les deux
juste pour faire avancer un peu le débat
aussi cet extrait de
l'interview donnée ce matin bruno
retailleau le chef de file des
républicains au sénat lui il parle
d'agenda caché des nationalistes il dit
on peut constater quand même que
monsieur talamoni où monsieur simoni ont
un agenda caché leur agenda a eu cette
sphère que petit à petit la corse
prennent le large
il est évident qu'aucun prisons de la
république française ne peux le tolérer
posture jacobine de finalement
d'emmanuel maquereau ou simplement
volonté d'éviter que l'accord se
prennent le large
je crois que la corse elle est
l'expression de l'erreur une forme d'
erreur de manuel macron dans sa relation
à la région c'est à dire qu'on ne peut
pas à la fois être super jacobins ce qui
l'a été depuis son élection et en même
temps affirmer une forme de volonté
girondine pour in fine et s'est retrouvé
confronté à un discours ou en tout cas
un dialogue du goût très direct avec des
corps constitués qui l'ignorent
et c'est exactement et la corse devient
l'expression de cette ambiguïté de cette
ambivalence du président alors
évidemment là il ne rencontre pas de
gilet jaune
il rencontre des drapeaux des drapeaux
avec une tête de mort alors évidemment
on est dans une situation différente la
corse est différente et je pense que
bruno retailleau n'a pas totalement tort
ce qu'il parle d'âge à cacher mais tout
ça ça n'a pas beaucoup d'importance qui
m'intéresse c'est que au regard de ce qu
est ce qu était la volonté du grand
débat il y a l'expression en corse de
l'inutilité de la volonté de passer par
dessus la tête de tous ces corps
constitués parce que là il se prend
engouement une réalité il a invité 360
mère 200 sont venus il a évidemment le
boycott de l'assemblée de corse et de
l'exécutif corse et il déclare qu'il ne
veut pas aller les voir et il fait une
double erreur il leur dit je suis prêt à
vous rencontrer à paris mais c'est
l'expression même de l'erreur les buts
je suis prêt à vous rencontrer même à
paris mais même à paris mais c'est un
thème c'est plus qu'un chiffon jaune -
chiffon à tête de mort
pourquoi ya pas eu de gilet jaune en
corse marc landré vous avez une idée
parce qu'il ya des corses
et pas besoin d'îles et jolie leçon
corse besoin de revêtir une quelconque
couleurs pour se différencier des autres
et surtout qu' un sentiment
d'appartenance à la peuple corse qui est
beaucoup plus large que à la classe
laborieuse comme dirait comme aurait dit
emmanuel macron donc c'est pour ça qu'il
ya pas de gilet jaune et puis les
revendications sont sauce aux sons sont
pas les mêmes ça veut pas dire que
là-bas il n'y a pas de gens qui
souffrent qui ont des difficultés à les
faire c'était la suite aussi la question
est ce que la situation économique
depuis deux ans que les nationalistes
sont au pouvoir local ne s'est pas
améliorée et que la base corse commença
à dire bah finalement c'est pas si bien
que ça va saigner améliorée ni détailler
en tout cas pas dire pas d'amélioration
notable papa dans des proportions
différentes de celles du continent
donc c'est pas être le problème encore
ce n'est pas hélas rarement été une
question économique c'est une question
d'identité
c'est une question d'appartenance de
communauté il donc d'accord voilà
françois payet 2 où est ce que
l'économie parce que là on entend des
jeux regarder un petit peu le début du
débat avec les maires la preuve les
principales interventions c'était pour
dire l'énergie alors avec le gros sujet
de louis l'écologie les infrastructures
non mais c'est vrai partout et ses yeux
d'ailleurs c'est c'est toute l'ambiguïté
de ce grand débat qui va voir tellement
de mal à acquérir s'ils nous sommes une
façon le polynôme accroc n'a pas fait il
n'y a pas un mandat catastrophiques loin
de là et les chiffres ne seront pas sont
plutôt meilleurs que ceux qui l'ont été
à voir ce que tu es fournies par son
prédécesseur enfin il n'y a pas une
situation aussi cataclysmique que le
semble le donner l'expression sociale
qui est aujourd'hui celle de la rue mais
effectivement il y a toujours des
difficultés à organiser un discours
qu'ils aillent au devant des français
qui a été au départ lors de la campagne
un discours très horizontale très je
vais changer la politique je vais
directement au devant du peuple un
exercice du pouvoir qui est hyper
verticale et qui crée les conditions du
projet et qui aujourd'hui se trouve dans
une ambivalence absolue entre je vais
retourner devant les français en direct
dans une horizontalité à laquelle
évidemment et sa sociaux voire en corse
il
roy plus les français ça le problème
alors qu'en pensent nos internautes aux
voleurs vous posez la question comprenez
vous que les nationalistes boycott le
grand débat d'emmanuel macron vous êtes
57% à dire que oui avec ses remarques et
vos est ce que une des demandes à ce
grand débat pourrait être l'indépendance
de la corse que s'est pas posé comme ça
le problème le problème corse et que
racaille on n'a pas tort les
nationalistes sont dans l'ambivalence
contrairement aux catalans contrairement
aux écossais il ne demande pas
l'indépendance de la corse y sont
incohérents par rapport à leur propre
logique idéologique
le seul qui est cohérent c'est talamoni
il est le seul à être cohérents mais les
corses ne sont pas sous nicole nous dit
la corse ne devraient pas avoir ce
statut particulier eric il n'y a pas eu
de gilet jaune ocre réponse à ma
question car les corses n'ont peut-être
aucun problème mais n'attend pas il faut
compter pas exagérer il ya beaucoup à
faire je vais fait un nuancier quand
même 2 par exemple le niveau de vie des
corses il est plutôt inférieur à la
moyenne du niveau de vie nationale
c'est une des régions les plus pauvres
de france pour c'est-à-dire qui a des
transferts importants de la main sans
faire offense aux français d'abord bien
avant l'europe c'est d'abord la c1 pour
la collectivité nationale qui transmet
ce qui est normal des reins et pas du
tout une remise en cause
il ya des alors il ya quelque chose qui
effectivement qui est comme mon gilet
jaune mais c'est pas effectivement il
est là tu as raison et c'est parce
qu'ils sont encore c'est qu'en fait tout
le monde est un peu dans le sud
le sub urbain en corse parce qu'il ya
très peu il ya il ya 25 il ya très peu
d'habitants 300 milles en tout qui sont
déjà dispersé donc tout le monde se sent
un peu pareil y'a pas l'idée de dire moi
je suis différent de celui de la
métropole dakota et s'il ya pas de
métropole en fait en corse
donc effectivement il n'y a pas assez de
dichotomie tout le monde tout le monde
ressort un peu commun et donc ça se
retrouve dans l'identité corse pour le
couple je vois aucune envie de
ressembler à des gilet jaune
ils n'ont aucune envie de se diluer dans
un mouvement qui n'est pas le leur avec
des couleurs toutes façons des valeurs
et pourtant alors les sujets qui sont
toujours ceux de la co officialité
français le terme de la langue les
détenus dits politiques sur l'île
et le troisième c'est l'inscription dans
la constitution de la spécialité
élections là ce sont des totems pour
employer il faut savoir qu'il ya une
base politique nationaliste en
particulier chez les jeunes chez les
plus jeunes il faut quand même les
satisfaire ces gens là donc ça soit en
raison d'une revendication identitaire
qui de toute façon et sans fin la seule
finalité de cette revendication
identitaire cohérente et logique ce
serait l'indépendance sauf qu'ils n'ont
pas de pensée politique cohérente
la preuve ils demandent la
reconnaissance de la corse par la
constitution française
alors que une bonne partie de leur
électorat considère que la corse n'est
pas une région française
donc le problème des nationalistes c'est
que ce sont des gens qui n'ont pas de
pensée politique consistante
je le redis avec regret parce que j'aime
ce pays j'aime ces gens mais il faut
bien constater que ans 40 ans 50 ans ils
n'ont pas produit une seule un seul
penseur un seul intellectuel un seul
théoriciens et c'est pas talamoni qui
peut faire office de théoriciens du
nationalisme corse
on a peut-être ainsi la réponse à la
question que vous pose est pourquoi vous
aviez écrit je suis corse et je n'en
suis plus fier mais j'aime beaucoup la
corse mais les femmes et qu'on leur ai
dit aussi j'ai écrit ce livre à une
époque où les nationalistes avait une
emprise sur la corse où il considéré
c'étaient eux qui décident et qui était
corse qui n'était pas corse on passe à
neutre
deuxième sujet toujours le grand débat
alors la sortie cette fois ci la sortie
pour certains elle ressemble de plus en
plus à une impasse
en tout cas les oppositions le à
emmanuel macron le prédisent et même au
sein de la majorité certains envisagent
un fiasco
tout le monde se demande donc ce qui se
prépare à l'elysée pour éviter ces
pronostics et les déjouer hier en
bretagne emmanuel macron a donné
quelques pistes
pas de réponse miracle nous dit le
président à public pas de chèque en
blanc qui préfère parler de projet
national et de sens du collectif
on écoute un risque du débat je l'évoqué
toutes leurs rapidement c'est
l'individualisme c'est à dire la réponse
au débat ça doit être 66 millions de
réponses et ne bouge pas j'ai mon
chéquier dans la poche et je vais vous
faire une réponse à chacun ce sera bien
et vous trouverez toujours des gens qui
diront mois on n'a pas répondu à mon
sujet aux grands débats peut-être parce
qu'à chaque instant faut jamais oublier